London is growing fast
another million people are expected to
swell into the city in the next decade
the result property prices both
commercial and residential are
increasing there is one phenomenon which
has pushed prices like no other
Crossrail the 15 billion pound rail
network cutting across the capital in
the area's five hundred to a thousand
meters around the stations we would
increase property values by an average
of 18 percent and here's why cross rail
will connect isolated parts of the city
to the very center of London's shopping
and business districts the property
market in London is cyclical caronia
Gilmore has researched for real estate
companies at night Frank
within monitoring prices in about a
10-minute walk zone around the stations
we've seen prices outperform in those
areas compared to the wider local
boroughs houses near Crossrail stations
have gone up 30% in value since 2008 and
a forecast to rise another 40 percent
between now and 2018
but it's not just homeowners rubbing
their hands together retailers are also
expected to benefit Crossrail purchase
large chunks of land for their new
stations making them one of the single
largest property developers in London
construction sites will be transformed
into buildings creating an estimated 2.3
million square feet of new shops broadly
speaking we're looking to generate about
half a billion pounds from property
development as part of the core funding
of crossbow the sale of the land will go
towards covering cross trails colossal
cost but not everyone is the winner
London's property boom is pushing up
rents and new renters have seen prices
jump 10 percent on last year some of
London's poorest areas are seeing the
highest increase in property prices good
for home owners costly for the city's
increasing number of renters Caroline
Hyde Bloomberg